[Applaudissements]
votre monde éveillé et modelé par les
rêves
des rêves et des cauchemars que je fasse
à
et qu'il me faut contrôler
il est allé à marc roche cherche c'est
ça vous rendez vous compte des dégâts
que pourrait causer
j'ai besoin que tu m'aides si les rêves
disparaissent l'humanité s'éteindra je
me passerais bien de rêver pendant
quelques temps j'ai pas eu une nuit
correct depuis des lustres
je n'ai pas l'intention d'arrêter tant
que je n'aurai pas changer le monde
alors dit nous tue le pouvoir pourrait
avoir les rêves en enfer
moment j'ai envisagé de claquer la porte
mais j'ai un travail à accomplir alors
je le fais les choses ont évolué
les yeux vont tous me raconter
tous vos sentiments toutes vos pensées
mes créations n'arpente pas le monde
éveillé en tuant des mortels pour le
plaisir vous croyez que les rêves ne
peuvent pas mourir on n'a qu'à vérifier
les cauchemars n'ont pas leur place dans
le monde éveillé
il s'avère que j'y suis très à l'aise
les rêves ne peuvent pas mourir tout à
merde
mais ça
les nuits
[Musique]